i recently
was invited to cambridge university in
the uk and spent
two weeks partly there partly at oxford
and then partly at a variety of
remarkable places in the uk
and then i came back to
north america and i was asked by a
newspaper
to
contribute an article
that was in some manner related to my
visit and so i wrote it and the
newspaper wanted to edit it a lot and so
i
found another newspaper that would
accept it the way i wrote it and
because i i wanted
to say what i had to say about it
and
i'm going to read it to you because
while that way you can listen to it and
maybe you'll find that useful
it's called it's very unstylish let's
say
why i love great britain
of all the twists and turns that my life
has taken over the last few years one of
the most truly upsetting
and surreal
was learning
that i had been
parentally disinvited from one of the
uk's great universities
in 2018 when i last traveled to the uk
i met with several cambridge professors
and began to discuss the possibility
of arranging a seminar there
focusing on some key biblical texts
a formal offer of a visiting fellowship
was
proffered to me in february of 2019
facilitated by dr douglas headley
professor of the philosophy of religion
at clare college
and arranged through the necessary
actions on the part of cambridge and the
university of
toronto
in the fall of 2016
i had rented a 500-seat theater
on a whim
you might say
in toronto canada
and delivered 15
90-minute public lectures
every week
a different lecture
entitled the psychological significance
of the biblical stories
surprisingly all 15 lectures attracted a
sold-out house
furthermore the majority of the audience
consisted of young men
a notoriously difficult audience to
attract
to such things the initial lecture
introduction to the idea of god
focused on the first two sentences of
the book of genesis
those who came to watch and listen
walked their way with me through the
remainder of that great book
during the remaining
14.
by the close of 2018 when initial
arrangements were being made
my fellowship some four million people
had watched the first lecture on youtube
with a multitude more
listening on my podcast the series has
now been viewed or watched 40 million
times it has in addition attracted
widespread positive response from
christian catholics protestants and
orthodox believers alike
even widespread positive critical
response
as well as large swaths of the orthodox
jewish and islamic faithful
in a further unexpected twist
the lectures have also proved popular
with those who regard themselves as
explicitly
atheistic
i recount this only to explain why the
initial invitation from cambridge was
proffered
it has proved increasingly difficult for
those concerned about our traditional
and religious heritage to propagate
their message their ideas to the modern
community and the success of my
strange venture generated
some great curiosity
after the success of the genesis venture
i had the ambition to continue my
investigations
and discussion
with the book of exodus knowing that i
am an amateur in such matters being
possessed of no training in formal
theology i thought it would be prudent
to test my knowledge and understanding
in a setting that would challenge what i
was assuming and potentially
rectify my profound remaining ignorance
i therefore set out with my would-be
cambridge hosts to hear the opinions of
those who had made the study of divinity
their central calling before i presumed
to re-engage upon my lecture series it
was a great honor for me and i say this
most truly to be offered this
opportunity as a psychologist and an
academic interloper my invitation raised
some hackles behind the scenes however
based on what i would call a willfully
blind misinterpretation
of my putative political views
in consequence
the invitation was unceremoniously
rescinded
on an excuse which i later learned
had been manufactured
after the fact this happened
conveniently
as well as treacherously
when dr headley my sponsor was absent
conducting his affairs in india
i discovered that i had been canceled
not as a formal notification
but accidentally on twitter
to say the least
this was a shock
earlier this year however i received an
invitation to return
in the aftermath
of my canceling and other two similar
incidents an intense battle had been
waged to make the sort of gratuitous
forbidding that had been applied to me
impossible a group of cambridge dawns
arose to challenge and reword a set of
revisions
to the university policy on free speech
that would have ironically if that word
is strong enough made future similar
cancellations both easier and more
likely then they attempted to find 25
people who would have fixed their names
to a petition that forced a full
anonymous and binding vote on the matter
this specific effort took months people
were afraid to sign afraid that making
their support for such a change public
would expose them to sanctions similar
in consequence to those that befell me
afraid that they would be
mobbed
and cancelled
but enough people
eventually did so and the matter was
duly brought forward to regent house
cambridge's ultimate governing body
and when the vote was called
an unusually large proportion of those
eligible to cast their ballots turned
out to make their opinions known
almost 9 out of 10 of the 1500 or so
who voted did so in a manner that made
such cancellations impossible in the
future
a larger margin of victory than any of
the academics i spoke with about such
issues of governance could recall
obviously
something was transpiring of far broader
significance than the mere revoking of
my individual fellowship offer
and so
to the first
of many reasons why i love great britain
cambridge like oxford from which it is
descended much as it dislikes to admit
it
has a highly decentralized college
structure both great institutions are
more a loose collection of autonomous
colleges each with their own history
tradition architecture peculiarities of
self-government and educational aims
this arrangement allows for maximal
liberty and creativity and thought and
action at the most vitally important
level
the local
while simultaneously enabling an optimal
level of cross-college rivalry and
cooperation
furthermore and most significantly this
free and loose organizational structure
makes
bureaucratic capture of the entire
institutions
extremely difficult
this in turn makes the rectification of
mistakes which will inevitably be made
possible and even likely and that might
just be the salvation of the rapidly
corrupting modern university as well as
everything downstream
from that culture
and that is everything
and the rebellion at that august
institution
and elsewhere
against the ideological forces currently
threatening free discourse and inquiry
in the academy
is just beginning
mark my words
my wife and i returned to cambridge on
november 17th i attended a number of
seminars there delivered two public
lectures as i did a week later at oxford
where i'd also been invited to meet and
speak and teach i used these
opportunities to discuss and test a
proposition
key
to the body of thought
i have been developing and communicating
about for many decades
that we all perceive the world not as a
set of self-evident objective material
facts but as a system of meaning
and that we do so by applying a
framework which when described
is a narrative
a story
i proposed further that this fact
has profound even revolutionary
implications for how we understand
science and technology and for how we
conceptualize ourselves existentially
in the world these ideas were markedly
well received i also had the great
privilege of talking for several hours
while at oxford first to sir roger
penrose perhaps the world's most
renowned living physicist and then to dr
richard dawkins who is rather uniquely a
fellow both of the original royal
society and honor bestowed upon
outstanding scientists and of the royal
society of literature
founded in 1820 by king george to reward
literary merit and excite literary
talent
dr dawkins is as well
perhaps the world's most famous and
influential
atheist
dr penrose and i along with dr stephen
blackwood who served as mediator
discussed his fascinating artistic
proclivity for geometric tiling an
endeavor related in my opinion to the
relationship between mapping a territory
and the territory itself
i spoke with dr penrose mostly to
inquire and learn as his knowledge roams
far afield from mine
and was well rewarded in my efforts as
our conversation literally spanned the
micro and macro cosmic realms
i spoke with dr dawkins
after long tentative
and increasingly amicable correspondence
beforehand to clarify my ignorance of
his well-defended positions particularly
in relationship to his opposition to
religious belief and behavior suffice it
to say in the latter case that we have
much more to talk about
i greatly enjoyed both opportunities
and will be releasing a video recording
of the former and an audio of the latter
in the very near future
i believe that these conversations
went very well
i certainly found them intensely
engrossing and informative and i regard
it as another great privilege and
opportunity to place them online
where they will be made available to
millions of avid listeners around the
world
i can do that
because i'm a free speaking citizen of
canada
a member of the british commonwealth and
except for our own sporadic and
inexcusable foolishness
a country shaped to the core by the
english common law tradition furthermore
i can make those discussions in all my
talks and seminars at oxbridge available
on youtube
the technologically revolutionary
platform invented by americans
who are even at the time of the
revolution and are still now in some
real sense sovereign british citizens
insisting on their due and intrinsic
rights
and
what would the world be
without the recognition of those rights
a stifling web of intrigue
a system of archaic dynasties
a tribal mass of clans steeped in
nepotism warring with one another for
access to the short-term exigencies of
power
i realize that there are other lights in
the world apart from the uk and its
subsidiaries and once dependence
although i would argue that even the
european countries that profess respect
for freedom of speech and thought
in reality fealty to the divine word
both secular and inescapably religious
have done so in no small part because of
the influence of that great land
and the fact that dr dawkins and i came
armed so to speak with radically
different viewpoints and conceptions was
a spur to our very productive
conversation
and not an impediment and the fact that
such discussions and their dissemination
are possible
throughout so much of the world rather
than positively forbidden and fatally
dangerous
is another one of the reasons i love
great britain
my talks at both cambridge and oxford
appeared uniformly welcome to faculty
and students alike
with a single exception a rather
courageous and comic young woman dressed
in a full body lobster suit who popped
in during my most public talk at
cambridge to shout feminism
and dance briefly about
why was that reception
so positive
uniform
and manifold
when i was apparently ignorant and
malevolent enough to be banned from the
campus
only two short years ago the students at
cambridge remained seated when i entered
the hall just prior to my first talk
although they had lined up down the
block for most of the day beforehand
well the oxford crowd anxious as they
are not to be outdone
gave me an overwhelmingly moving
standing ovation before i spoke there i
say that
not in triumph
i hope
as that
would be the sort of pride
that deservedly invites a fall
although i might need to confess
occasionally harboring at least a
quizzical smile about such things
such a public response
seems
at curious odds
with the idea so invidiously insisted
upon that i was and am a fundamentally
maligned person
characterized by literally unacceptable
political opinions the same mode of
interaction
made itself evident
in what were many dozens of encounters
with individual students on the streets
and in the colleges at oxbridge
no fear
no disgust
no contempt
no hatred
just a series of extremely inviting
pleasant
and often surprisingly deep and intimate
individual encounters
with fine mostly young people
striving with all due effort upward and
onward
informing me
forthrightly
that they were doing so
perhaps an inquiring and curious
journalists could discuss among other
issues
the fact of my fellowship revocation
the regent house vote
and the positive response to my presence
at cambridge with the soon to depart
vice chancellor
another canadian
we are a pesky and intrusive lot
professor stephen tupe
whose precipitous retirement from the
glorious uk academic and cultural scene
was somewhat synchronistically timed
given the aforementioned vote and my
subsequent re-invitation
or perhaps it could be discussed
all of it
with a tiny number of individuals still
meddling madly and unrepentantly behind
the scenes who orchestrated the whole
false thing in the beginning
and the fact that a journalist could
inquire about such things
is yet another reason why i love great
britain
with its profound commitment to the idea
that the curious have the right to
interrogate and investigate those who
have been granted authority
or usurped power
after our university sojourn after
having been granted access to the
original writings of charles darwin and
isaac newton after attending the most
beautiful imaginable choir accompanied
services at the magnificent chapels
gracing both institutions after
walking down the helloed historical
halls of higher learning in a setting
constantly overwhelming and remarkable
for a mirror colonial accustomed to
history on a much more minor scale
my wife and i were privileged to tour
the british parliament accompanied by
one of the peers of the realm
she was great
if i might be so bold to say so
everything a hopeful outsider
uncorrupted by the pervasive cynicism
that corrupts our time might have wished
for
kind charitable engaging unpretentious
articulate elegant
and possessed of that wonderful accent
bestowing upon its possessor the
immediate impression of high
intelligence
in the palace of westminster i stopped
for a moment
at the precise center
of the heart
of that remarkable building and lifted
my eyes upwards
directly under the immense chandelier
suspended under the beautiful and ornate
domed octagonal ceiling
i understood then that i was standing at
the base
of the realization in stone
wood
and the air itself
of the cosmic tree
yggdrasil itself the lyanna
joining heaven and earth
the object of the most ancient of sacred
visions and religious transports
the very lifeline
between the transcendent heavens above
and the suffering and fallen earth
itself if i could have asked for
something more to befall me at that
moment
it would have been the music of the
divine to accompany that vision perhaps
box great third brandenburg concerto
although i would have settled for the
british national anthem
god save the queen
that lobby
is
most certainly not
the untrustworthy corrupt and damnable
site of power dominance and oppression
but the very place where the practical
redemption of a great people is
continually undertaken governed by the
and necessary principle
of the unalienable right to express the
logos as conscience soul and rationality
itself dictate
that lobby enshrined in that palace
the cardinal castle of the word
has been a very light unto the world
realized there simultaneously in stone
tradition
and living action
it is the very place where the sovereign
voice of the people meets the voice of
its representatives to be carried forth
into its eventual incarnation into the
body of laws we separately and jointly
accept adopt
and act out
we are all carriers of the temptation to
resentment
and the desire to compel and force those
who disagree with our presumptions
that poses an eternal threat to the
integrity of our souls and our societies
we are all possessed by the attributes
of the auschwitz capital the gulag
trustee the willingness to turn away and
to consciously deceive and the capacity
to delight in oppression and cruelty
we are each and all of us tainted by the
blood that soaks our soil
but the people of great britain have
granted the world a gift
whose power stands in permanent
opposition
to our most appalling proclivities as
individuals and societies that gift is
the political expression of the
sanctification of the word freedom in
speech
imagination and thought
freedom to engage in the very process
that builds and rebuilds habitable order
itself from the chaos that eternally
surrounds us
and that freedom is expressed in many
ways small and great in the british
isles in the wit of its people in the
effectiveness of its institutions in the
beauty of its art and literature
in the political and psychological
presumptions that guide private
discourse and public conception and
action
and that is most particularly why i love
great britain
and that is why people of that realm and
not only of that realm
you should love her too
despite your sins
with your eyes lifted upward your hope
to the future
and the word of truth
and faith
on your
tongues
i love your country
rule britannia indeed
you